yes I feel honored
I honestly didn't expect either
but I like it very much
and I can do this to my foundation
let it grow further
well I was especially very surprised
because I did not expect
but I am very happy
and the winner is
Omnia
the winner is Sandra
these young people are 2 of the winners of the Yang impact
Awards
these prizes are awarded to young people every year
who are committed to social initiatives
1 of them is Sandra
she won in the diversity category
because of her theater performance
my performance is called bindefetter
and it's about putting yourself away
lose and reinvent
it's based on my life as
vitamin most Dutch girl
in which I actually tell my life story
no pain but also how i do that
overcome Ben also tell
unia won 1 award
she got the prize
because she is with her self-founded foundation
makes poverty negotiable
I have actually lived in poverty all my life
I have quite a few of those myself
had moments when I did not get over De Heuvel
then you have bureaucracy again
or then you have again
other incidences that constantly work against you
and I know I'm not alone
those young people win 1 amount of money for their project
1 boost
for sports you have performance psychologists
so I'm also thinking about maybe 1
performance psychologist
but aimed as an artist
we hope to join our next event here
financing that is actually for Ramadan